dans ces jardins familiaux il est 10
heures en plein hiver et ces
travailleurs n'ont pas froid aux yeux
plantation de fleurs de légumes de
fraises ici travail de la terre se
conjugue à la rigueur qu'exige le milieu
professionnel pour venir en aide à des
profits tous différents au quotidien on
fait des plantations en fait c'est pour
montrer aux gens qu'on peut planter sur
des petites parcelles une véritable
passerelle restructurantes pour ces
adultes en perte de repères en recherche
d'emploi ils ont été aidés par et qualys
une association qui a parmi ses
objectifs
l'insertion par l'activité économique
c'est pas forcément pour en faire des
futurs jardiniers ou des techniciens en
espaces verts pour les collectivités
mais c'est surtout un support qui leur
permet de se redynamiser de sortir de un
peu de leur quotidien et d'être
accompagnés vers un véritable projet
professionnel
l'idée c'est vraiment de leur redonner d
un cadre au niveau du professionnel
savoir arriver à l'heure le savoir-être
être présents ne pas être absents écouté
les consignes comme dans n'importe
quelle entreprise professionnellement ça
m'apporte beaucoup non seulement le
savoir être et le savoir faire que
j'avais déjà mais ça c'est un plus une
belle occasion également pour les
rencontres et le partage c'est vraiment
un échange chacun
à son sens son savoir donc tous les
savoirs se partagent on a vraiment cet
esprit d'équipé en parallèle aux jardins
familiaux une boutique a ouvert il ya
trois ans à chanteloup les vignes elle
emploie également du personnel en
insertion la création de cette boutique
il ya plusieurs objectifs c'était de
répondre à un besoin de commerces de
proximité offrir voilà aux habitants des
produits locaux et des fruits et légumes
bio 2 c'était de créer de l'emploi et
permettent à des personnes éloignées de
l'emploi donc sans emploi de retrouver
du travail et de venir travailler dans
ce dispositif qu'est la boutique et 3
c'était de le troisième objectif c'était
de travailler avec les agriculteurs
locaux et de valoriser la production
locale avec un même objectif servir de
tremplin les personnes qui travaillent
dans cette boutique sont des salariés en
insertion ou en transition
professionnelle on dit parce que ce sont
des personnes qui sont à la base à la
recherche d'un emploi donc sans emploi
on est un tremplin pour eux pour les
aider à retrouver un emploi plus perrin
derrière j'étais un chercheur d'emploi
et un concert du récemment parlé de
cette association du coup bas
j'ai fait en sorte de postuler ici ça me
permettait d'intégrer doucement le monde
de travail une initiative valorisante
pour le personnel depuis le début j'ai
dit récemment portée de la confiance ça
c'est important ça permet de renouer
avec le monde du travail au centre la
première chose qu'on va regarder c'est
sur mon cv ceci dit j'ai de l'expérience
dans le domaine et là
c'est le cas j'apprends un cercle
vertueux entre productions locales et
vente de proximité qui permet à de
nombreuses personnes de retrouver le
chemin de l'emploi chaque année